ok
[Musique]
oui
moi
l'ong ainsi ça fait plaisir besoin
bienvenus si la première à ouvrir les
vannes gouffre tous connaissent et
robien j'évalue pour le reverra plus
tard malgré le programme des spectacles
est venu faire tant qu'ils marchent et
coquine est bienvenu je suis contente
d'être là je suis pas venu pour tailler
le bout de gras avec mal au dos chez eux
ouah je suis content vous ça va c'est
bien c'est bien je suis contente
d'autant que papy et jenny m'ont dit tu
vas voir naître ici au prisme on a un
public d'ados sont pas des malades un cd
vieux ça n'a rien à voir ça sans pareil
en mais ça n'a rien à voir
le problème comme ça c'est juste voilà
on se dit les choses là on va passer la
soirée ensemble
c'est pas comme ça que j'avais imaginé
notre première rencontre moi j'ai fait
le voyage jusqu'ici je me suis dit sont
motivés les gars ils me veulent
c'est sûr je vais arriver je vais être
bien mais là j'arrive je suis léo ferré
en terme d'ambiance avoué que c'était
pas tout à fait voilà moi je me fais
beaucoup de films un tête mais c'était
pas c'était olala vous avez des têtes de
décembre là on vous obliger à venir
monsieur dit oui qu'est ce qui vous est
comme ça mais je vous ai manqué il est
père mais cette position langage du
corps c'est l'inquiétude ou la castro
ainsi redit de bienvenue monsieur
détends-toi se passer et vous savez quoi
je pense que vous et moi on mérite mieux
que ce qui vient de se passer
d'accord donc ça va faire c'est qu'on va
refaire ce début on va faire comme dans
ma tête d'accord je vous explique
comment ça va se passer je vais revenir
vous allez vous lever tous monsieur tu
es chef de groupe
je te mets la pression natale à castres
où tu n'es même pas peur quand je vais
revenir tu vas te lever ils vont dire
mais il a raison avec elle leader
charismatique qui vont tous se lever val
où je compte sur toi aussi à comment on
se connaît bien sûr vous avez vous levé
tous avec trèbes hausse avec historique
ici au prisme stand région d'entrée donc
vous allez taper des pieds attaquer les
mains bougent et tout ce que vous avez à
mes hanches artificielles madame je ne
veux retenir ça
c'est pas mon problème la terre 20
tremblay d'accord les gens vont passer
de dordrecht rivaux tels que se
passe-t-il c'est un tremblement de terre
c'est un tsunami
là c'est l'ouragan nadia roz qui est en
train de ravager les côtes des
spectateurs du théâtre du prisme tapas
prix des places bien fait pour ta gueule
c'est ça qui va se passer dehors
d'accord je vous aime déjà quelqu'un
dont vous êtes prêts alors c'est parti
action
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs vous voir si la
seule l'unique scène qui vous est venue
ce soir
mais là monsieur en direct en couleurs
en dogme s'alarment en 3d en panavision
non merci
santé des ondes
puis ce soir
là
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
[Applaudissements]
allah je suis à mon max de convivial et
on la garde c'est bien d'un casting
s'inquiète voix c'est formidable on va
pouvoir commencer la soirée
ah quel bonheur d'être ici avec vous si
je suis venu en plus ça c'est bon pour
vous parler d'un truc que moi qui va qui
me fait beaucoup de bien qui me paraît
un peu de bonheur si jamais très marrant
le bonheur mais si mes moyens
tranquillement vraiment heureux c'est
depuis quelques années maintenant que
deux petites années gg le grand bonheur
d'être maman comment je vous respecte
les filles maintenant je sais
respect à ce que marco montpoint
quoi qu'est ce que tu n'as pas compris
la première fois moi je suis un peu
binaire sait pas ce qu'on va sûrement du
mois le truc de la maternité c'est pas
mon affaire desquels on m'a dit tu as
par nadia c'est magique c'est
merveilleux ça va être le rôle de table
ronde de l'année alors je vais dire
admettons moi je veux bien s'y être
maman c'est le rôle d'une vie dans ce
cas-là l'accouchement c'est quoi la
cérémonie de remise de prix
bonsoir et ce magnifique bébé de 3 kg
304 humain est attribué à nadia un bébé
je m'y attendais pas du tout
j'ai rien préparé il est magnifique
il est superbe mais dans l'autre sens
sur j'ai peur je me suis arrêtée deux qu
il est parfait je suis très ému c'est
elle n'a par contre il faut que tu la
fermes pendant le skate surf est
important je te dirai tout faire mais là
non parce que c'est important c'est la
première fois qu'on me remet un bébé
j'ai pas par où commencer je voudrais
remercier toute l'équipe technique qui a
vraiment fait un travail formidable sur
ce projet ma première pensée va pour
catherine télam à catherine la sage
femme catherine merci catherine prend la
petite robe trop mignonne avec le petit
décolleté au niveau du cou
je remercie patrie il est la patrie de
l'anesthésiste merci patrick stud la
pomme grâce à toi j'ai gardé tout du nom
alors que j'aime en flammes à reims il
faut il est là je te remercier gérard je
suis une personne gérard tu sais j'ai
peur je n'ai jamais dit avant mathieu tu
m'a vraiment fait ça petit ru meilleur
de moi même
tu sais quoi ré large et des chiffres et
puis turc oumou sy sarr s'implante à
vous avez c'est drôle mais quand leurs
producteurs et est venu me voir avec ce
projet j'y croyais pas beaucoup
bah il a insisté il m'a fait passer son
petit bout des serres oui c'est plus que
ça
éviter cette image l'approché ray le
projet a été conçu comme ça en deux
trois minutes
l'ordinateur que si c'est assez drôle de
ma vie j'aurais jamais de césar grave
j'ai compris en l'expression donner la
vie c'est joli nom donné la vie
je sais que c'est la mienne de vie que
je devais je sais pas vous les meufs
mais moi depuis que j'ai donné la vie
j'aurais pu finir enfin ma vie on voit
la roxy là bas on s'appelle t'inquiète
conserver leur ne te vois tu me parles
mais je suis comme tout le monde
d'accord moi aussi je fatigue moi si je
craque
chaque jour dans le monde des millions
de femmes craquent et personnes n'ont
pas non monsieur pas le baby blue ses
terres jeu dur la vergeture c'est quand
tu essayes de faire entrer yolande
moreau d'andré tautou
ya conflit
là c'est les satyres ça pète ça craque
c'est moche sachez que 70 % des femmes
ont des vergetures c'est la statistique
officielle 70% donc là on a un panel par
faire vraiment là là là là on ne vit pas
dans crâneuse la la la la la crise
apporte quoi je vous ai fait 70% les 30%
restants sont de grosses limites
alors le premier mois poser beaucoup
cette question qui intéresse beaucoup
pesé alors quand même ça va la nuit ça
se passe bien il fait ses nuits tout ça
alors pour ça j'ai eu du bol un petit
bonheur il dormait comme un bébé
c'était génial et puis pour le réveiller
c'était facile il suffisait de le poser
dans ce sens mis tout le monde chiale
air bag of stéréo dormir comme un bébé
je t'explique 1 ça veut dire se
réveiller toutes les trois heures et se
chier dessus voilà pourquoi je conduis
dormir à poings fermés
on s'affaire salle vous le dira vous
avez vu à nouveau les deux prêts
dernièrement neuf mois pour ce chantier
mais fait moins y'a rien qui aux normes
je te fais cette fois c'est pas fini ça
n'a pas de cheveux ça n'a pas de danse
ababsa son pipi comme ça ce sont pas
autre chose ça ne fait rien ça journée
quand sa part on ne comprend pas fini ça
ne marche pas encore d'un surnom sa
rampe à même le sol ça n'a aucune
dignité c'est les clochards
me réveillais moulé bbcd claudon puis
c'est tout la compression coach a rien à
dire je le sais est le mien avec son
doudou des 101 dalmatiens qui pue la
mort c'est un punk à chien oui oui bah
oui je parle de toi oui eh ben va bosser
il va envie de chanter comme un des
anarchistes rakkad respecte moi je suis
le travail trop y en a un qui fait ses
nuits
et ça ça fait plaisir c'est bien comment
fais tu pour dormir c'est la galère
dehors et toi tu dors dans ça chamboule
tout dans le couple tout est plus fort
plus grand plus intense tu vie les
émotions à fond lui tu les mets oui tu
l'aimé mais ça c'était avant
maintenant tu veux tu qu'ils crèvent
le tout sous la main
sophie la girafe la bouche pas peut-être
l'idée jamais c'est pas une personne te
respecte dans cette baraque lui nuit
quand il veut quelque chose la violence
tout de suite c'est des racailles
finalement c'est sale et bbcd racal je
le sais lemire je l'amène à la crèche le
premier jour et là il ya une petite
racaille de 14 mois qui arrivent sur lui
dis là le gars cela raconte beaucoup
trop puisque genre il ses marchés j'en
ris line dance
ok oui ma poule toulouse à nouveau qu'il
voterait attend des frères des soeurs à
dakar sa dirais tu connais pas en
violence ça n'a jamais été fait membre
d'honneur
je suis le kwassa kwassa de faire moi
les sifflets moi le film où je crois pas
au crash ici
quoique je prends les bases ont mis des
barons sur lady gaga dans sleeping à
cacher son doudou à s'emballer
crouch de tomber je suis blindé
tu es ma poussette c'est une mclaren
frais je te promets pare-soleil adidas
doublant son 300 voix par l'arrière du
bon faut un support s offrir cet apport
discret discret moi je dois prendre à
paris en ce moment je supplie dean of
study cause mais ce coup ouattara foulée
square garden mais largement comme ils
sont moins sucré cette merde asie pose
pas de questions c'est tombé de sa
poussette
allez-y circulent dans toute affaire dit
bougez bougez alerté tout à fait baroque
mais bout filtre qui me traverse
étonnant mariage tout cas fait que c'est
tout un business affiche ou capable et
c'est pas parce que les yeux dans les
yeux
nous quand on a besoin de la leur de
l'eau à temps se situe à loulou à
l'envers ça fait quand même new look
nous la racaille je vous dis il ne se
censure sans foi ni loi ne respecte rien
toi la nuit tu dis bon allez c'est mon
petit moment de détente je vais
récupérer un petit pointu posé là bas tu
es giflé par dan ait tu sais plus le
temps d asie et au bout de ta vie tu en
mode rôle king bed fait toute blanche
thaddée c'est comme ça tu as les cheveux
en pétard
tu chantes des chansons chalus tu as
l'impression d'avoir bouffer trop de
mylène farmer
tous
ils sont glam et sexy
merci alors ta faute de patrick à mende
rodez aussi messi 678 cesser la moyenne
d'âge est responsable oui on peut dire
ça
alors oui oui du match quel est ton
actualité en ce moment est bien en ce
moment figure toi que je joue sur un
plateau à elancourt du prisme et que bah
ça se passe plutôt pas mal l'accueil est
très chaleureux on a un public vraiment
dans le faire non plus sérieusement je
suis au théâtre jusqu'à la fin du mois
donc dépêchez vous les garder à trotter
à au théâtre des mathurins da corella 7
7 5
voilà le plus jeune c'est ou c'était un
petit peu plus à paris voilà c'est passé
les dimanches et les lundis au théâtre
des mathurins dans la grande salle donc
venez nombreux et qu'est ce que je peux
te dire un peu de dates de tournée c'est
un peu de fiction voilà ça c'est cool
voilà voilà mesdames messieurs 1
c'est quoi l'humour c'est aussi nadia
roz mou c'est ça crie ça va moins ça va
alors nadia ben écoute moi je suis bien
là bah oui mais là il va faire d'accord
à 100 pour signaler mais il ne vous
voyez vous ok j'y vais en moonwalk
[Musique]
pas de big n
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]